hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
this is another episode in looking at uh
what's inside high resolution music um
this analysis is a little different in
and it's by request to look at the
high resolution samples provided by the
great label 2l
the nordic sound as you can see their
website over here
they distribute pretty high quality uh
music
but i know the service they provide
which is wonderful for the community
is this uh sampler page where you can
actually download music for free at
practically every sample rate and
resolution that you might be interested
in
all the way from cd quality to uh dxd
and stereo um 352 kilo
sampling rate um so it makes for a
wonderful uh
workbench to look at what's inside high
resolution music
they're nicely tell you what the source
format is in this case is the xd
so this large file at 410 mega megabytes
is the original master in stereo
then their versions in in stereo i have
the 96 killers
version and i've also downloaded the mqa
and
cd so let's go ahead and
look at the these files in addition
i'm going to start with 96 kilohertz
sampling rate and let me move this back
to somewhere interesting and
before i even play the music if you've
watched my previous episodes you already
see the problem
um look at these three peaks in here
they're occurring 38 kilos on up
and obviously they're not musical
information as i've explained before
music has this nice exponential roll-off
more or less
and there is no musical instrument that
just generates these high
very narrow pure tones almost
signals way into ultrasound um
whoever produced and mastered this music
just like me
and the rest of you can't hear those so
what they didn't hear
they didn't catch but they should have
just done this simple
objective analysis that this window of
frequency analysis exists in every audio
application
so they could have just pulled this up
found these
and eliminated their sources what are
the sources the pure ones again as i've
explained before
probably the scan rate of monitors
bleeding into the sensitive inputs of
the
analog to digital converter these wider
noise ones
are less pure you know there could be
alarms in the building or if it's
captured from tape
which i don't think this one is um it
could have been bias
signals that are used on real-to-real
tape recorders but regardless it's not
our job to
discover what they are it is theirs they
could easily turn equipment on and off
and
until these peaks go away and not
deliver these to us
another nice phenomenon we see this uh
good learning exercise is that as we get
close to our
final frequency of 48 kilohertz which is
the bandwidth we can have in a 96
kilohertz sampling you can see this nice
anti-aliasing filter
that necessary to get rid of what is
called aliasing
and it pulls things down to -180 dbfs
which is
great um so that's natural that's good
what's not good is this so let's go
ahead and play the music and see if we
can figure out what the usable
spectrum of music is how much of this we
really need it
so clearly this part is going up but if
if we let it play we see that
it actually does use uh the rest of the
uh
most of the rest of the spectrum also
let it get louder see you can see this
part is
jumping in correlation with music and
that's
important lesson to learn music is not
a random thing an instrument of plays at
this frequency has overtones that play
here and the two have to be correlated
if there's nothing here
then there's just noise but a real
instrument generating high frequencies
will extend here is a good example you
can see how naturally
extends so i'd say eyeballing it
about 34 kilohertz is
is what we need to preserve doubling
that to get the sampling rate that would
have been 68 kilohertz
we don't have 68 killers uh sampling air
8
and the nearest one would be 88
kilohertz
so if this kind of music or the original
capture should have been 88 kilohertz
and uh that unfortunately would have
captured some of these tones
um but wouldn't have generally delivered
to us bunch of extra noise
um now here the extra noise 88 betw
the difference between 88 kilos and 96
kilos is not that large but now let's go
to the
original master and uh see how wasteful
this
is um so this horizontal scale is hugely
expanded this is 352 kilohertz sampling
so the bandwidth is now half of it or
180 kilohertz or so
and uh if we go back to the previous
display the previous display truncated
around here
we still see our original ultrasonic
tone in here
uh still present and uh but what's right
after that we see this hugely rising
noise pattern and that's typical of low
bit rate of one bit sampling
because we don't have sufficient number
of bits normally
tons of distortion would be generated in
the audible band
there's a process called noise shaping
where we take noise out of the audible
band
and shove it into ultrasonic range the
idea being that we can hear
noise in the audible band but we can't
hear it in the ultrasonic range
so all the noise has been emptied out of
here
and shoved into ultrasonic by definition
then
we don't want to play this this is noise
that is not musical information it
should be thrown away
and the idea was that we don't hear it
and throw it away indeed
some sacd players or i don't know if all
of them have a selectable filter to
actually analog filter to actually get
rid of this noise and this hash that's
coming out
yet in the case of high resolution
digital download we're now handing all
this to
users and people happily go for the
larger number being better
352 is much nicer sounding that 96
kilohertz
so let's get all that and attempt to
play that
so nothing good comes out of playing
this noise on your stereo the amplifier
may oscillate make it distort
your twitter may cook may distort may
cause intermodulation
it may actually generate distortions in
the audible band
or may do nothing and that's the best
case situation where it does nothing
no reason to distribute all this no
reason to originally capture that such a
high sample rate
again an 88 kilo sampling rate would
have been plenty would have
been just nice and it would have
truncated
everything to the right so no goodness
comes out of this
now scaling all the way down to what
would have been a cd release
let's go ahead and listen to the uh
16-bit 44.1 kilohertz sampling so now
our horizontal scale
uh truncates down to 22 kilohertz or so
and uh let's play this content again
and let me see if i can find yeah there
we go
oops pay attention to here
when it gets quiet
there did you see this peak point now
peeking out uh this is a pure tone again
or a set of tones
they're not musical there's not part of
music we can see the
the level of the music is naturally
dropping off but this part is not
it gets masked when the music gets
louder than it but otherwise it peaks
out
this is much more problematic than the
high frequency ones because
it's in the audible range it's about 19.
some kilohertz
was it caused by i don't know uh some
instruments something electronic is
generating it uh it's unfortunate i mean
that's this is
egregious uh means even in cd we're
hearing it let me play that some more
there it is you can see it very clearly
uh picking up now it's very low level
but you know still we want to have good
quality uh
there it is i mean it's just
unmistakable that this is not natural
nothing here does that you see this nice
exponential
clean uh uh roll off
and uh she should have sailed into the
sunset the same way
so unfortunate unfortunate for sure
now lastly let's get into a new form i
call mqa
master quality audio it's a new format
being introduced and it's claimed to
fame is that it encodes high resolution
audio high sample rate audio
into low sample rate distribution format
in this case 24 bit 48 kilohertz i
believe let's
open that up now this one is actually 44
kilohertz sampling rate
and but inside this you can actually
decode and get the
what used to be above here and uh
how does it do that well if you go back
to the original
display we can see how he's going to do
that this area is the audible frequency
range
and we you know pcm format which
you know 16 or 24 bits is spent
encoding this but as we get to our
ultrasonic if you look at the level z
in here the 125 db efs
these are very very low level signals no
way do we need to have
a dynamic range that describes them all
the way up to zero
i've never seen any high resolution
content as
much of anything uh above these very
very low levels so what we really need
is just a few bits to encode the
this spectrum that's indeed what mqa
does
um if we go back to the uh
mqa signal and uh
let me zoom out a little bit
we see what looks like a cd rate but
then we see a strange phenomena over
here where
they actually the noise floor rises in
here why is the noise flow rise in here
because in here mqa actually attempts to
encode the information it needs to
generate the rest of the bandwidth to
the right
and so in that regard it is degrading
the cd
rate no question about it this now
this is very very low level you know
audibility is a different question than
objective measurement but if we play
this
we can see that this part of this rising
spectrum did not exist now luckily a lot
of it is above ultrasonic and
again for us old folks we don't hear it
but the rise starts around 16 kilohertz
or so
so clearly the very high frequencies
have had a random noise added to them
and that information actually isn't
random it's actually uh
correlated to what spectrum it wants to
generate above this point
but it's been randomized to make his
audibility very difficult
um you know i haven't done any double
blind tests to see if
if i can hear that i believe others have
and they sort of kind of could um set
the extreme this this may be audible
depending on the content you play
so there's a price to be paid it's
backwards compatible
mqa is that means just as i'm doing
right now i'm playing this without mqa
decoding
yet the music plays and i hear it but
there's a compromise
in embedding that in here i believe for
other content they
use 48 killer sampling which allows this
to be shoved further up above the
audible bed
right now it's at uh 16 killers
so that's it uh hopefully you're finding
these uh episodes uh
useful uh i know music's about art and
enjoyment and
uh you know not about what's going on in
here but i think the industry needs to
do a better job
in producing and delivering high
resolution content to us that's pristine
that's clean
um because that's what we pay for we pay
a lot more for these high resolution
downloads
they're not on sale for little next to
nothing on amazon to go and buy the cd
and so we expect and rightfully so uh
pristine quality masters
and uh not something that has extra
tones in it and noises and what have you
okay again this is amir from
audiosciencereview.com
talk to you later in a future episode
bye